all right so there's our basic forms
let's rewind a little bit come back to
Ted and you know sometimes they give you
a slightly different question they'll
say Ted X is equal to 10 something else
okay or sometimes I'll say you know 10 3
X is equal to 10 5 X what do you do okay
well then apply this pattern again but
I'm gonna notice that see right or 10
inverse or see if one I but for C is
also itself 10 something right I'm gonna
have tan inverse of tan this angle tan
inverse of 10 which for the domain that
we're interested in is just thicker this
is gonna cancel right so you gotta
remember tan inverse of tan X is equal
to X early with his sent domains right
because if you take X out you know some
other like something crazy light angle
and I say you know 15 PI or something
like that you get 10 of that and then
when you take tan inverse it goes back
within your normal domain okay so this
is only sometimes but it's good enough
for us because we always want those
sometimes so therefore if I've got this
situation then I can change it a little
bit
instead of saying x equals 10 inverse of
C I can just put that is alpha that will
be the end goal I'm interested in plus
okay same logic here if cos x is equal
to cos alpha right this color format
here for X is equal to 2 n PI plus or
minus your beta angle which would just
be a fun hey one more time if
excuse me so I actually could sign out
for a gala bit less this thing on the
end with M PI plus switching fee
okay now so one got in black is the
basic forms what I've got in blue I
cannot forget again Spanier but you get
the idea you do have to say that because
you can't introduce variables at random
or eject what I've got it blue is where
you've got trig functions on both sides
and then you noticed as well that for
instance with this one and with this one
even though we like having everything in
terms of one equation because that's
nice and neat and it captures everything
anyway when you've got our far like if
this was you know 3x and 5x we noticed
that we could do some simplifying here
right we could say if this was 3x and
this was 5x I could take the 5 x over
bar and I couldn't you know actually
have I could collect like terms right
that was the useful thing but to do that
you've got to break the equations apart
again in order to actually make that
okay so let's consider rub off these
graphs
let's consider what happens to these
general solutions when we break them
back into two because I remember
spending several time this because I
remember having a lot confused by this
why will we I thought was good to have
things in one why did we break and panic
in what's the point okay so example
let's do the one that I've just been
talking about okay so in this case we
just start off at this point here except
instead of X and alpha I've got 3x and
5x okay yeah I'm usually that tradition
is to keep the bigger number as your
subject it doesn't really matter you
don't talk about the same you just have
less negatives flying around to see why
in a second so I'm gonna make that my
first angle okay
that's equal to two n PI plus or minus
3x so far so good just a substitution
okay now this is correct but it's fine
but I can make it simpler by breaking it
back apart so let's let's do that okay
over here on the left hand side I can
say let's take the case where it's
negative okay so it's 2n pi minus 3x
okay so because I can take this Irving I
can work with it another that's that one
yeah add three it's the both side so you
get 8x and of course we just want One X
by its utter so that will be M pi okay
then you take the other side and you say
let's treat the positive case two plus
three X again you gotta like terms so 2x
by the way you can see if I put three
its over here and 5x over there let's
don't work I just get two months / -
tada and then you notice all of a second
all of these solutions
this is shorthand for zero PI 1 PI 2 pi
3 PI and so on all of these solutions
are already included in this set because
this is
0.41 949 or etc okay so for pile for
corresponds to one time but so therefore
you know even though this is true I
actually don't need to worry about it
this is fully sufficient okay doesn't
ask me questions that's cosine besides a
bit trickier because of this some is
switching so I'm gonna get rid of
tanning cause and let's have a think
about science right okay so let's do 3x
and 5x again
sine 3x sine 3x and okay so I start by
writing just the one equation okay so
I'm gonna have 5x is equal to M PI plus
you're switching thing times 3x okay and
just as before like we have with the
plus or minus
I can't simplify this any further into
present form because that's switching
thing I can't do anything that's in the
latter right so how do I break this
apart into its two forms okay will you
remember what we're trying to take into
account here is that for odd values of
Pi it does one thing and for even values
required does another thing okay so I
want to think about the whole and even
its let's think about the even ones
first
okay because that's 0 that's 1 0 and
then 2 pi and in for piles
so if I want even lots of pie even lots
of hype and from even while they went
forward I don't force oh okay all the
even numbers are this is 5x all the even
numbers aren't to Empire okay that'll
give me zero two four six eight okay so
this is looking a little bit like the
coast Network right for the even lots I
go forward so plus 3x okay all right now
now I can simplify take that 3x across
two x equals two okay should look
familiar because just like the cosine
one exactly the same result then when
you do this part odd values of Pi how do
we get on down use what's a way what
kind of expression can we use to
generate all the odd numbers was two
different ways right I can get to n
minus one or I can go to n plus one can
you see they give me exactly the same
certain numbers because I'm thinking of
all of the ends all of the integers okay
the reason why I'm making a note of that
I'll do it - is because to legitimate
different ways right I can make a plus
or minus and I'd get different answers
at the end so this is the explanation
for why you go to a textbook you've
solved the general solution and you're
like mine is totally different to this
well maybe it's not that different
cuz it looks different okay okay so this
is the odd value addition of Pi and for
the odd values you have to go backwards
okay hope you're basic
so now let's simplify it X
all right so X is okay now I like with
our cosine example okay this side here
and this one here they do not overlap
right in fact they yeah they should
never overlap because I'm always gonna
have lot numbers here over an even
denominator so it'll never simplify out
to be just the whole number okay
so in this case I've got to include both
so my final conclusion is x equals n PI
or PI on 8 plus 1 so I remember people
getting very very confused by a
particularly this side one because you
start out with this switching thing and
then it just vanishes and starts to look
like cosine my braining what's going on
okay all we're doing is we're breaking
it apart for the purpose of simplifying
further see these lines are working we
cannot do as long as that minus one to
the end is there okay so there's your
general solutions